up until this point everything's okay
you know we go to the baggage
thing our bags ain't coming yeah
everybody else has got the bags right
and then
the police just come around with guns
and save tamira you
boom hands up in the air this and that
oh no they're right
now
[Music]
the childhood was uh all a bit rough i
had to stutter
and i couldn't speak english till i was
four and i couldn't even really talk
probably loads of getting caught black
getting spun people trying to burn our
houses down
i was on my own lone wolf no friends
nobody there
it was just me just hitting and that's
when i become a dorm
it was from the doorman i started to
train myself start the box
take steroids so i was buying them
taking them
and the other dormant they wanted them
as well so i might know okay i'll get
you some as well
so originally i was just going to
countries like turkey spain
uh greece just bringing back a few
a few hundred pound worth and i like
four times my money on it
and then it got to a stage where i
worked with a couple of cousins of mine
and thought right listen let's take it
to the massive stage here yeah
let's uh bring this in ourselves instead
of these small little
things we're doing here let's just go
and do it properly i
took so we source a place and the
cheapest place to buy
steroids is karachi pakistan
uh because at the time al qaeda were
active the taliban were
in kidnapping everybody and we were sick
boys
indian sikhs and so we were told you
don't want to be going there
me i didn't get about that yeah i just
don't know i'm doing this
when we landed there yeah when these
chemists yeah but they said no we can't
supply any more than this
uh we only have five ampoules available
i said no we need a hundred and fifty
thousand yeah they went nowhere
we can't you know that's impossible
anyway went about three
four and then this one guy said listen
there's one
company in karachi town and they
organized the full pill market and this
is how the meeting
went down with him uh he wanted all the
money up front he said yes i can stop
i can get you that mountain man yeah how
in how long
he went next day it'll be off if you
packed my two cousins said no
don't have the money over here because
that's gonna last we're gonna
see this we ain't gonna see that money
again listen there's no other way of
doing it
and we have to show a bit of trust here
and
i think the guy likes me you know i gave
him the money and he tapped on the
ceiling this hall just appeared
you give them money and this kid come on
got it and scampered across
that was that and then my cousins were
looking at me thinking
right chet are you in control of this i
went yes i am in control of this
are you then he told me come back here
tomorrow 2 p.m
and everything be solid and he was a man
of his word it was all there
done dusted i used to go through karachi
airport and bypass all security the
first time around
it went like this about some bags on the
x-ray suitcases
open them up full of steroids bomb all
of it and they said well
this and they're looking and no no you
can't take all this through you're going
oh listen we're trainers you know we're
bodybuilders fighters
no no no no and then they noticed the
pawn mark
and then one of them picked it up and
they went uh
do you want it he goes yeah all right
yeah listen i said
i've got two more here yeah one for each
case here and
when we walk you all right okay because
in pakistan
you can't get no pawn there's no such
thing as a pawn magazine back then here
and here there's another two geezers and
that's the same problem there but i
thought listen
the porn mugs worked that time around
here let's try these
so we paid these two guys off and we
were like wow
we've walked through airport security by
paying off with five pawn mugs
brilliant we changed at amsterdam
okay uh but on the karachi flight we
just got pissed
right the three of us got pissed forgot
about the problem in hand really
and uh when we landed in amsterdam
i think there was a five hour wait for
the next flight that
from amsterdam to newcastle and this was
a sober period this is where it was all
sinking in a little bit on the three of
us
we were sobering up now and it was uh at
two o'clock in the morning
and we were like right okay
didn't even speak to each other yeah we
were we didn't even speak to each other
because we know
what we've done we've come this far what
else does it
say right i'm wearing listen trust me
it'd be all right i said
i know these amsterdam flights we went
through customs
got the bags and then a big sigh
high fives was six weeks and then we hit
it up again
you've done one trip now yeah and then
where did it go from there
uh anyway we did another trip and then
the money was coming in the money was
coming in but uh they just wanted to
stick with the steroids
but i wanted to do the volume what's
higher risk
uh but they weren't too keen on that one
they went this and then we had a bit of
a falling out and then blah blah blah
you do your thing i do mine all right
okay and now the volume is where the
dollar was
i was paying at a time for a thousand
tablets
nine pound street value is a pounder
tablet in scotland two pounder tablet
so the money i was making was silly and
that's when i started to take mules over
uh i'd pay for the trip pay for the
holiday
pay for all the expenses if they wanted
to pay for that as well and then i'd
give my granddad in the hand afterwards
really i would just pick people who i
know who aren't going to open the mouth
to the police if anything if anything
happens
uh they will take it on the chin that is
the whole point of a mule really two
mules i flew from newcastle
to barcelona barcelona
to karachi and then from karachi
to alicante up until this point
everything's okay you know
we go to the baggage thing our bags
ain't coming yeah
everybody else has got the bags right
and then
the police just come around with guns
and save tamira you
boom hands up in the air this and that
no they're right
now and then they pulled our cases out
handcuffed us i had a emerald ring
i had a watch i had cigarettes in my
case the police just took all that
took it took my ring took my watch took
everything
i said do i get receipt for that and you
just put his hand on his gun
and he went you want a problem i
wanna take what you wanted until we won
so i got taxed by the police there they
were laughing
wow look at all this because they said
this is the biggest seizure in spanish
history
they even knew that themselves and they
were all taking
photos of it themselves and it was in
the newspapers the next day
there's a biggest seizure of classy
pharmaceutical drugs in spanish history
and it still is people telling new york
and 10 years here you know
what what for volume when i know that
can't be no no no not in spain there was
somebody got nine here for having four
tablets
because he intended to sell them
so they gave him nine years for the
intention to sell
four tablets so now i think i've got a
quarter of a million
right spanish jails are supposed to be
the worst in europe
and my wing is the worst wing
so i'm thinking right i am i am the
worst
place in europe ever because this is the
worst jail
the worst wing in the worst country and
with the worst people
the russians had to click the germans
had a click the south americans that i
clicked
the moroccans and algerians the muslims
they had to click but i'm neither of any
of these people
but i just i was just on my own i didn't
fit in anywhere here
and i just had to do the work on my own
there and i've done
so when you it do the work what do you
mean do the work is
knocking people out baby that's what
doing the work
is when i was falling home
and then they were saying to me chat man
have you seen the newspapers
all right no i'm like well i haven't
seen the newspapers
interpol i've been watching you blah
blah blah
it's not a long good baby it was only
after a matter of time i've been there
about over a year
i got talking spanish and then i
spoke with the top heads uh the bank
robbers the kids that were doing
done for 160 kilo a hash from morocco to
spain
and but these boys said listen you need
you need a bent lawyer
he went because he's the only one who
can give the judges a bribe
all right okay then hook me up hop me up
with that
hotmail went through the process he was
brilliant
i paid him eight grand in total
eight grand and he got me
four and a half years and that's for all
three of us and so by then we're already
done
we only need to do three years of that
and we've already done about two and a
half
two in a bit so it was all happy days
right the first day of freedom i was
that high
i was just wearing my shorts and a vest
and this was like october
no this was november i think
and um i was training in the gym and i
was that excited
everybody was like hugging me saying oh
you're going home you're going oh yeah
yeah yeah
so i give away all my falls i give away
everything
didn't realize i was that happy i got on
a plane
coughed just to my shoulders and vest
took me to gatwick
the three of us and then um they just
like
took the cuffs off got worked they
phoned the gallery police
has he got any warrants here and they
said no
and they just took them off and they
left me there boom they were right now
go
with no money no nothing it was middle
of the night and just my shots my vest
so what made you go straight
getting sent to 11 years in total it's
too much
for anybody it changes you if you up and
it's a hurt that you put your family
through
well not only that it's like it's like
everything you
you don't let me the fool huh
as yuri was bringing the spacecraft in
for the the first manual
approach we were just aware that things
were not going right we had another
failure
which meant the computer screen went
down so tim and i were effectively blind
and that was the point i realized this
approach
is is just not good and yuri actually
his hand started
trembling on the controllers